The Joe Rogan Experience so this uh Rod
tank fight one of the things that's very
interesting about one FC is how they're
just really mixing everything up they've
got grappling matches you know Mikey
musumechi's over there competing Gary
tonan the Rotolo Brothers it's like it's
very wild what they're doing they're
having Muay Thai matches kickboxing
matches that without one boxing match um
which was for a WBC Title so oh yeah it
was um I believe boxing gloves boxing
gloves full blown boxing like it was a
world uh World title fight
um that's one of the things I love about
one Championship is that they're mixing
it up right so when I got the
opportunity to go over there and compete
like I knew I had the opportunity to do
something fun like I did with raw teen
right now was it difficult to make that
decision to leave the UFC because you
you were you know coming off of a very
close controversial loss to Henry sahuda
very close fight yeah you know it was
like mostly the wrestlings a couple
takedowns that he got yeah it was a
couple takedowns and I think I relied
too much on lay kicks like I like and
that fight I couldn't get him down to
the ground
um the schreiken scene on the feet like
with the hands it seemed like it was
pretty even I was I think I outlanded
him like when you look at the strike
strike copy block strike numbers but I
felt like I relied too much on the lay
kicks because I was I was [ __ ]
tearing those legs up well you hurt his
leg real bad in that first round yes he
got that drop foot thing going on yeah
he had to drop things going on but I was
like I couldn't get there with the hands
right I couldn't knock on the hand so I
was like you know I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna take your material leg up kept on
tearing the leg up and when the fight
ended and I was like ah he probably got
it I was like he he beat me and then
they read the score card and I was like
huh it is what it is like what are you
gonna do so what was the decision after
that like what was that like so it was
frustrating
um but then you know at the time I was
like I wonder if I can do something
different right because I was going in
the back and at the time Naki Maki was
in uh managing me he still is uh
professional managing is and I was like
he said you tell me what you want to do
bro you know just let me know and we'll
figure it out and I was like I wonder if
I get on my contract I was like you know
try to do something different because at
the time
I looked at it this way if I were to
fight himachudo again for the third time
it couldn't go either two ways one I
beat Henry then I'm still stuck in the
same situation I am right now when at
the time they're trying to get rid of
they're in talks about getting rid of
the fight with division right or two if
I lose to Henry then I'm still stuck in
the same position I just lost him again
so why not see if I can go explore other
options right and then that's when the
trick talks came about and so the UFC
just said fine go ahead well there was
more to it right I mean
obviously um you know Chacha just you
know talked about it it was uh I heard
you had something to do with it as well
like yeah I did yeah yeah well um I'll
get to that point so obviously
um you know they wouldn't been asking
has been one of the fight in UFC for a
long time right and then so one
championship and UFC were talking back
and forth between Hunter and Matt Hume
and Maki sir like hey let's do a trade
right like we'll give you been asking
for Demetrius Johnson and then at one
point I heard that you know Dana was
like nah I don't I don't I don't want to
make that happen right I don't know the
fool I'm not in the rumor all the puzzle
pieces are being shifted and then I was
hanging out somewhere and then somebody
said you know Joe Rogan had a PC now and
I was like really he goes yeah and I was
told that you kind of convinced it I'm
like who gets a [ __ ] like just get get
been asking or something like that so
yeah I know right so that's not really
accurate No I definitely was trying to
get them to get Ben asked him but I was
trying to get them to get Ben askren
back when he was a Bellator when he was
in his prime yeah you know I was like
listen man this guy is wrestle [ __ ]
everybody I want to see if he could do
that to the whole division like when
when Ben was in his prime when he did
that the car scoff we did that to uh
Douglas Lima I was like you gotta
understand how crazy this is that this
guy can do this to everybody yeah and
people say oh it's boring it's boring
it's fighting Yep this guy is you
imposing his style on these murderers
yeah I mean korzkopf was a murderer and
Douglas Lima is a [ __ ] Savage and he
was just ragged on these dudes and doing
it weird ways I remember he he has a
funky style about doing things and I
remember somebody said he was training
with him and he was able to twist and
turn a certain way to where if a normal
human being would do it they would like
tear their cartilage in their ribs and
he was able to do that and bring him
back to where he was and I was like yeah
dude that's that's a freak right there
but he's always wrestled like that
because he's not like a physically
imposing guy I'm sure he's very strong
because he's been wrestling his whole
life but yeah his style was always like
this just weird style that was very
difficult for people to understand so
they would they would try to like do
traditional [ __ ] with him and all sudden
they'd be on their back yeah it just
didn't work by the time we got him
though he was already [ __ ] up needed
to hip replacement and he was already
retired right and so that's that's what
I heard and so when they were want to do
that trading like yeah we'll take
Demetrius over Ben because Demetrius is
still active and he's still you know
still I always look at myself as a
Workhorse right like I will you're
paying me to fight I'm gonna fight right
and so I think it was a no-brainer for
them and that's that's how it happened
well I definitely would have kept you in
the UFC so that's not I'm sorry
sweetheart
I mean if you look at guys like Davidson
figuerado Brandon Moreno there's some
amazing fights for you yeah absolutely
and the Flyway division is sort of risen
up yeah there's there's a lot of like
very interesting contenders now yeah but
I don't have any say in like which what
goes down yeah but I'm not the guy
why am I saying you were the winner I
was like we need to make this happen
okay when you make it happen like I just
heard that you kind of had like some
type of persuasion I guess you can say
when you guys were out and about but
that's what I've been told like I said I
don't know the full story because I'm
just an athlete I'm just hey this is
what I want can you guys make it happen
then I'll let the higher-ups like Hunter
Matt Hume Maki they're doing all their
pieces and then you know [ __ ] well I
know that could have been a [ __ ]
rumor all right so it's definitely a
rumor oh well there you go it's a rumor
don't believe everybody here I
definitely was excited to see Ben ask
her and come over to the UFC but and
also as a fight fan and I was excited to
see you go over to one yeah because the
same way I was excited to see Eddie
Alvarez over there and I I think we need
more events more competition is good one
that's good for everybody absolutely and
what you're seeing now with one FC is
these world-class [ __ ] guys